over the years we've talked about rising
automation machine learning and
artificial intelligence these are three
different topics but they do relate to
each other and today we're going to take
a very detailed deep dive into
automation and what I really see as the
inevitable need to reconsider the
relationship of humans to work and
humans to employers in the coming five
ten twenty five years in the United
States let's get right into it the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
all right a very very big week for the
David Pakman show the Joe Rogan
appearance a lot of other stuff so let's
go to the phones and see what's on
people's minds at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's start with our caller from the 205
area code who's calling today from 205
hey David this is uh this is Corey
welcome back from California thanks
Corey what's going on so when I watched
your interview I think it was for the
second time with about College he pushed
back about the trades and emphasizing
the trades more and not and not being
formed you know in particular fully
subsidizing let's say University based
education one of the things that came to
mind that I want to ask you for a while
is why not instead push for fully
funding trades maybe as a starting point
and then to expand let's say towards
subsidized or you know fully subsidized
university education well what would be
the reason to start with trades I mean
it's so you could start anywhere or you
could do both or you could do neither
but what would be the reason to do
trades first how would that help us
eventually get to subsidizing fully
subsidizing State College well I think
that thought would be at least in my
mind David would be that if you are
tackling what would be more in demand
right now so taking taking Andrews
concern let's say that that trades are
heavily under represented in the United
States versus many of the other European
countries in particular focusing on
trades first as a way to you know not
just get a better representation but
also start to mitigate some of the
incoming problems around automation and
how that might affect job opportunities
in the United States
listen I don't know that the automation
question is going to be better handled
by more trade school versus more
bachelor's degrees I think that really
the fundamental question around
automation is going to be what portion
of the gains from automation go to the
business owners versus the employees and
the way to think about it would be
imagine a company with a hundred
employees automation makes it so that
you you only need 50 employees plus some
machines to get the same level of
productivity there's basically like
three possibilities for how those gains
are used in sort of like a purely
vulture capitalist system you would just
lay off the 50 employees you would keep
only 50 and the company gets all of the
gains of that technology in a socialist
system you would keep all 100 employees
and the doubling of productivity from
the technology would allow every single
employee to just work half as much in
like a social democracy setting we would
say ok some portion of the gains from
that technology can go to the business
owner and then some portion should be
distributed among the employees and
where you set that line like is it 5
percent or 95 percent for the employees
depends sort of on your political
philosophy I don't that's a reality
regardless I mean that's gonna happen in
both a program school jobs rather that
you need a bachelor's degree for and
jobs that you would go to trade school
for and I think it's just a broader
economic question I don't know that we
solve it more or less by saying we're
gonna focus on funding trade over
bachelor's degrees ok all right great to
hear from you Cory appreciate it very
much we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two David P take
a listen to this voicemail that came in
about social democracy and technological
unemployment
hey David my name is Justin I'm from
Washington State and my question is who
as a social democrat should we be
opposed to automation taking service
jobs away from working-class people
thank you okay so this is a really good
question whether you're a social
democrat or not the the right answer
here is a simp
historical efforts to oppose technology
on the basis that it would destroy jobs
have failed period we could probably
find some examples where there has been
a successful effort to suppress a
technology at least temporarily on the
basis that it would destroy jobs but
historically saying we need to suppress
this coming technology because people
will lose their jobs has not worked what
we need to take seriously is rethinking
the relationship of humans to work for
example technological automation if you
imagine a business with a hundred
employees technological automation could
make fifty of those employees
unnecessary and one way that the
business could respond would be to say
we're replacing 50 employees with
machines we're keeping 50 employees 50
people lose their jobs it doesn't have
to go that way the other way that it
could be done is the business says well
what we're going to do is keep all of
our hundred employees but they'll each
work only two and a half days a week or
four hours a day instead of eight or
whatever else now obviously the business
is not going to be willing to use the
entire gain from the technology and and
give it all to the workers but maybe
they say we'll keep our hundred
employees and they can work six or five
hours a day instead of eight and we will
sort of split the gains from the
technology now obviously there needs to
be some reason that the business would
choose to do that and there are people
including Bill Gates who have started
floating ideas and and sort of thinking
about different ways in which we might
be able to make that happen but no I
think that it's not only misguided I
think most importantly it's a futile
effort to try to oppose the technology
on the basis that jobs will be lost we
need to rethink how the gains from these
technologies should be distributed and
that's where 90% of the issue is okay I
will tell a bunch of vacation stories on
the bonus show today including to dog
poop stories I don't know that we've
ever really had dog poop stories on the
show and I regularly visit Argentina so
it makes it all the more incredible that
there haven't been dog poop stories on
the show anybody who's walked around
Ueno situs will understand what I mean
but I do have two dog poop stories today
and a whole bunch of other stuff become
a member or a patron to get instant
access to the
show let's see who else is holding on
here let's go over to the to15 area code
caller from to15 who's this hi David
this is Evan from Pennsylvania hey
what's going on Evan nothing much I have
a question I wanted to pick your brain a
little bit about automation so this is
kind of worrying me because you know I'm
in college right now and a lot of my
friends are getting jobs to kind of help
pay for food and stuff like that you
know lower end jobs those are
increasingly becoming automated and now
the higher end jobs with advancements in
hey I are they might become automated so
with that many people will probably not
be making money and in a capitalist
system this might perhaps our economy
and do some real damage so I wanted to
ask do you prefer stopping or heavily
regulating automation and provide ok
isn't cut out you just cut out there
after asking me if I want to regulate
automation what was the second part of
the question
oh and by tax cuts to employers through
employment and don't all right your your
cell phone service is going in and out
so I think I've got the question I'll do
my best to answer it so I think that the
there is an inevitability to automation
that is just it's just a real thing it's
happening ok so I don't think that
efforts to prevent automation are
particularly good places to put time
money energy effort call it what you
will
I think it's going to happen the
important conversation that we have to
have is one that is much more difficult
than tax cuts for employers that don't
automate or restrictions on technology
the real conversation we have to have in
the economic system that we we have in
the United States
in many countries is we need to
reevaluate
the relationship between work and humans
Homo sapiens and humans they're in a
capitalist system there's a certain
relationship there which is basically
your worth is determined by the job that
you do and how much money you make and
as automation continues to grow that is
just not going to be a good way it was
never a good way I should say of
assessing people's worth the society but
it's gonna be a particularly poor way so
universal basic income guaranteed jobs
programs restructuring the economy in
other ways revaluing assigning economic
value to intangibles like art and music
and exploration investigation stuff like
that that's the real serious
conversation that has to be had it's a
much more difficult one then let's tax
robots for example and that's the one
that I've seen no willingness for any
national politicians really to have and
I don't totally blame them for their
lack of willingness because there's no
upside to that right when you're running
a campaign you've got to say
I'll bring manufacturing jobs back and
then your opponent says no I'm going to
bring them back the real conversation
right is a lot of those jobs are not
coming back they don't exist anymore and
more are going to go out of existence
let's deal with that but there's really
no political upside to doing that so
you're more for like kind of like
economic rewiring of relationship all
right absolutely cool thank you for the
call appreciate it
great to hear from you the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com it's great to welcome to the
program today Neil Irwin who's the
author of how to win in a
winner-take-all world a new book about
navigating a successful career in the
modern economy he's also a senior
economic correspondent at The New York
Times
Neil so great to have you on today
thanks for having me David so I think
that in the last six to twelve months of
the political cycle increasingly
discussions about work are related to
number one a coming technological
unemployment and what jobs that will
destroy versus what jobs it will create
questions of minimum wage some broader
questions about the relationships of
human to work humans to work but let's
step back from that a little bit I mean
if we look at the last 50 years and the
idea of working for a company for an
entire career pensions which are
increasingly not available to more and
more workers how is the landscape kind
of changed about the relationship of
people to to their jobs in the United
States yeah I think what it means to
have a job has really shifted underneath
our feet over the last last 30 40 years
as you say
and I think the important thing is to is
to understand those changes and
understand what that implies for for how
you navigate your own career so what I
did with this book is I tried to go
around to these big companies that are
dominant in the modern economy and asked
ok what does it take to succeed and
thrive in this organization and then
what does it take to have a long and
durable career we can talk more about
some of the some of the lessons I
learned but I think you're you're
fundamentally right I think when in a
world where you know employers are not
going to be loyal to you necessarily you
can't count on that job you have being
the same job 5 or 10 years from now I
think the important thing is having a
kind of reciprocity and having a sense
of honesty that you know career is a
series of changes a series of steps it's
more like a series of hookups than it is
like a long time a long term marriage
and I think that's the most important
lesson about how this economic change
what that implies for the rest of us so
there are some who will hear that a sort
of general overview and say well that
there's nothing natural or necessary
about that change
in the sense that if only there was X
type of regulation that may maybe that
that change may have been restricted for
example there are others who will say
that those changes are more about life
expectancy and the fact that people may
just by their nature live in more places
and work different jobs and that's a
good thing and and companies are just
sort of reacting to those desires and
there's really not a problem
per se to be fixed here how much of this
do you think is regulation related how
much is socio-cultural change in the
states how much is something else
altogether
so I think there's two pieces of it as
you suggest and and part of this is
choices we've made as in through the
political system and as a society that
don't have to be made this way right
you know unions have become less
powerful there's been kind of you know
the entire gig economy rests on the
legal interpretation of independent
contractor law and and you know
companies are able to kind of outsource
things because the law allows them to
and you know those are choices that
could be made in Washington that would
tilt the other direction and that's kind
of what this next presidential election
is gonna be all about is what what
should those what should those settings
look like but I think I argue and I
really strongly believe that part of
this is driven by technological
fundamentals and and things that aren't
really going to change no matter what
happens in the political system so
things around rapidly changing business
models for example I work in the
newspaper business right you know there
is nothing that could have that
government could have done that would
result in the print newspaper not
monopoly is still existing the way they
did 20 years ago and I started my career
it's digital media and that's has an
entirely different way of working and
and requires different types of skills
than the old more linear kind of print
model did you know in every industry you
see changes like that
retail finance you know certainly any
element of technology and I think we'd
be foolish if we don't acknowledge that
those changes are driven by really
powerful fundamental forces and learn
how to adapt and respond accordingly
yeah I mean so thinking about those
forces in in preparation for our
interview I read some opinion pieces
which suggested that actually they're
certainly going to be significantly
different outcomes in one's career based
on the industry in which they work I
mean there are industries that go under
or
significantly reduced in size and that
in those cases there may be factors
bigger than one's own sort of education
and and kind of actions and personality
but that in many cases it's not so much
about particular skills but it's more
about personality and I guess you would
call it social skills understanding such
basic concepts as it's really important
for your boss to like you because if
your boss doesn't like you in corporate
culture it's going to be extraordinarily
difficult to get ahead no matter how
good you are at what you're doing and
sort of these other social dynamics and
I find that really interesting but I
also find it dangerous because there are
people who take that approach who like
to use it to defend drastically unequal
economic outcomes so while I find it
interesting and probably partially
accurate I don't want to go overboard in
that direction I'm curious what your
thought would be on the skills education
personality factors in terms of
dictating or predicting success yeah so
um sort of a concept I kind of develop
in this book of something called a glue
person and what we see in these the big
technologically sophisticated companies
that are the superstar firms that are
the real winners in this winner-take-all
economy they they have team-based work
and pull together people on teams with
very different technical skills so you
know you might have a software engineer
working with you know a finance person
working with a you know user interface
person working with a strategy person
and you need all those skills to come
together to create a great product and
so the people who are really effective
are those who can make a team more than
the sum of its parts who can help that
team stick together that's why I call
them a glue person and I think
cultivating your ability to be that
person is is really important and edit
to the personality piece it doesn't come
naturally to everybody it is something
we a lot of stuff to work on but
learning how to communicate and
collaborate with people who have a
different kind of technical background
than yourself is just a really really
important thing and I think is is really
a crucial thing to being the kind of
worker who's really valuable and needed
in these types of organizations that
that are really the future and the
present of the economy when it comes to
technological automation and there has
been so much written about the degree to
which this is going to be a problem
and specifically in which industries or
types of industries is this going to be
a problem how much is it being discussed
now within the corporations you
interviewed people and talked to for
your book yeah I think it's the it's the
predominant shift that's going on and I
think the real question is you know is
automation a I machine learning all
these things all these technologies that
are potentially enabling lots of
different jobs to go away I think for
most of us the thing to do is ask okay
how can I be the driver of that change
the person who is creating those
algorithms creating those new ways of
working and not a victim of it and you
know it's a it's a scary thing to think
that you know a computer might be able
to do my job in 10 years but if I'm the
one trying to figure out how to create
the algorithms create the software that
can do that job I can have a long and
viable career it's it's certainly scary
but I think you know there's always been
productivity there's always been
technological change question is can you
become the driver of it rather than the
victim yeah I'm currently in the middle
of reading the book life 3.0 by max
tegmark which is mostly about artificial
intelligence but it does address issues
of technological automation more broadly
and one idea he had and it may have been
him quoting someone else I don't
remember offhand was the idea that the
jobs that are going to persist and
remain through automation are likely to
be the ones that operate in subjective
spaces rather than objective spaces jobs
where for example personality does play
an important role or jobs that are more
related to a subjective advice rather
than objective analyses of data so to
speak that type of thing do you have any
strong feelings one way or the other if
we were to start trying to categorize
now the types of jobs that will and will
not be automated away I think we can
definitely start doing that and I think
that framework that you just laid out is
is very much accurate um so I you know I
have some examples in the book so if you
know in medicine for example if you're a
radiologist who looks at you know x-rays
all day and tries to identify things in
the x-rays that's the kind of thing that
really can be automated and increasingly
is you know an area where software can
be really effective if you're an
emergency room doctor that's never gonna
be automated
very much a human touch very requires
great flexibility great kind of quick
intelligence to see what's wrong with
somebody you know it's that's not gonna
be automated in our lifetimes in in the
law and legal business right if you're
reviewing contracts all day if you're a
lawyer just reviewing contracts for you
know possible problems that's the kind
of thing the software is getting better
and better at if you're a courtroom
lawyer if you're a trial lawyer well as
long as we have the legal system we do
now that's something that that's still
going to be viable so I think you know
there's basically two choices one was
what I was saying a moment ago about
being the driver of technological change
in your industry being the radiologist
who helps make that software work the
other approach is is choose one of those
jobs choose one of those paths that's
going to be very hard for computers to
catch up to humans is this something
that should already be figuring into the
majors that students in college are
selecting to me it's less about what
your major is in college it's more about
what you do while you're in college I
think the the key thing I learned over
and over is the importance of
adaptability and the cultivating and
ability to try different things stretch
outside your comfort zone and I truly
come to believe that adaptability is not
just a trait you're either born with or
not it's something that you can
cultivate in yourself and the way you do
it is by pushing yourself in new
directions and the best time to do that
is when you're either in college grad
school early career jobs where the
stakes are relatively low and if you you
know fall on your face it's not as big a
deal so what that means is whatever your
core major your core subject to you know
is stretch yourself in some areas
completely different from that so if
you're a you know if you're a literature
English kind of words person you know
take a couple of hard computer science
classes try a language that doesn't come
naturally to you if you're more of a
math person a numbers person you know
maybe write for the student paper or you
know go out for a play in college do
something that's pushing yourself in new
ways and keep doing that over and over
you keep doing that in your teens and
20s it'll become a lot easier to do it
in your 40s and 50s when you're in your
career
I believe that eventually I don't know
if it's in five years twenty-five years
or fifty or a hundred years but
eventually there's going to have to be
some sort of serious re-examination of
just the relationship of humans to the
concept of working a full-time job
either for hourly wages or salary in
order to
be able to achieve a sort of viable life
in the West so to speak we can talk
about it more worldwide but in the West
maybe we can focus our conversation do
you agree that that re-examination is
going to have to take place if so when
do you think it's going to have to
happen and but maybe most interestingly
are any big corporations thinking about
that at this point in time so I do think
we have to kind of reopen these
questions you know famously uh back in
the 1930s john maynard keynes thought
that by this time we'd only be working
you know three hour work weeks or
something like that
didn't quite go that direction so i in
the last chapter the book i tried to
kind of reflect on what I had learned
about about having a thriving good
career and I did some laughs and the
math is this so if you start working at
age 22 after college he retired 65 if
you sleep eight hours a night if you do
the math works out to about four million
hours you have to work with over the
course of your kind of prime working
years you know those are your waking
hours and and look that's the hardest
constraint of them all and we all have
trade-offs to engage in between our jobs
our hobbies and and pursuits and our
families and kind of home life and I
don't I'm not trying to be prescriptive
about how to juggle those trade-offs I
you know I titled this book how to win
not how to become a billionaire or how
to become a CEO of a fortune 500 company
because those paths aren't for everybody
and I think there can be a really
rewarding life to be had that that does
treat work differently than that kind of
always on you know we've got to put in
80 hours at the office kind of culture
and I think the important thing is being
deliberate and thoughtful about what you
find rewarding where your ambitions go
and and reacting accordingly you know I
think smart companies are realizing that
you know there can be a role for people
who only do a part-time schedule who are
willing to sacrifice a little income to
you know have a more you know 20 30
hours a week instead of 40 or 50 but but
you know I think that I think as time
goes on I think more companies are going
to realize that they need that ability
to to adapt with people's desires and
kind of work life the trade-offs are
there specific decisions you've made in
your life that most people wouldn't
necessarily think to be
because you work in this space and
research this this topic yeah I think
the UH I think the biggest thing that
I've really kind of internalized is is
an idea that is actually from Reed
Hoffman who was the founder of LinkedIn
yeah he calls it tours of duty and
that's the concept that's existed in the
military and in the diplomatic world for
a long time but in the corporate world
the idea is after you spend a certain
amount of time doing a project building
something whatever you were hired to do
then you have a real discussion with
your employer and is there a way to to
stretch yourself in some new direction
take on some new project I'm kind of
breaking up your career into into units
so I I call it the 3-year itch first
year in a new job you're just trying to
you know get up to speed second year
you're hitting your stride you're
getting good at that job then the third
year rolls around it's time to start
thinking about what's the next thing and
can I stretch myself in some new
direction it's doing that over and over
that helps on that adaptability theme
we're talking about a minute ago in my
own career I've done that partly by
changing jobs a few times but also by
doing something like this book and for
me you know I've been at the New York
Times for about three years when I kind
of looked around and said okay what how
am I going to push myself stretch myself
in a new direction and this book was
came out of that super interesting book
we've been talking with Neil Irwin who
is the author of how to win in a
winner-take-all world the book is about
navigating a successful career in the
modern economy he's also a senior
economic correspondent at the New York
Times Neil thanks so much for talking to
me and congratulations on the book
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today Ellen rupal she'll who is a
correspondent for the Atlantic also
author of the job work and its future in
a time of radical change
Ellen it's so great to have you on
thanks for having me David it's so to
begin with we've been talking sort of
piecemeal for many years about
technological automation the
possibilities of universal basic income
examining the areas of our
socio-economic system that are working
well in the areas that that are not
working so well but it seems that often
missing from this conversation is the
reality that at a certain point humans
are going to kind of need to re-examine
the relationship to work and the idea of
a sort of 40-hour full-time job as the
sole path towards other than independent
wealth sustaining oneself in the world
can you talk a little bit about sort of
the big picture of the change that you
see happening in terms of humans and
their relationship to work
David you put that beautifully okay and
what you just described is precisely why
I wrote this book my concern going in
here was that we were in something like
a denial national denial about how
things were changing economically
socially on all different kind of all
different levels and what we were doing
was desperately trying to hang on to
jobs that were no longer salient in the
current economy right jobs that that
would were being outsourced jobs
increasingly that are being automated
and we weren't really coming to grips
with the fact that jobs per se might be
on the way out
okay now historically jobs are kind of a
new idea I mean it's hard to imagine
this
but before about 1900 or so most people
didn't really have jobs right
most Americans worked in agriculture
they either own their land or worked on
farms many also had trades and more
entrepreneurs of a sort so the whole
notion of happiness was not really
necessarily a positive thing as you can
imagine that an agricultural community
if you had a job that means you would be
holding to a landowner you were say a
farmhand that was your job but what you
really aspired to have was your own land
and be something of an entrepreneur so
the whole notion of having a job has
really only since the late Industrial
Revolution and you know going forward
into our current century obviously that
21st century has held such cachet and
we're hanging on to this idea that we
all need to be working for someone else
right and we need to be employed in a
certain kind of way and all this to me
seems a little nostalgic and a little a
historical because in fact that's not
the way it's always been and going
forward you know that may not be the way
it's going to be and we need to come to
grips with that and understand what
steps we need to take to ensure that
everyone is able to afford to live is
able to make a living and also is able
to find a sense of purpose and meaning
in their work so you talked about the
discussion of bringing jobs back that
don't exist anymore
and this has become extraordinarily
politicized and what I've pointed out is
that if you have two presidential
candidates for example and they argue
about who is going to bring back for
example manufacturing jobs from Asia or
whatever the discussion may be as soon
as one of them says the truth which is a
lot of those jobs just don't exist
anymore their opponent says that's a
defeatist attitude and that's exactly
why you should vote for me instead of my
opponent so how can we break through
that and actually start to think about
what we're going to do
in reality instead of fantasizing about
bringing jobs back that don't exist when
there's no political incentive to do it
based on how our election system works
right again
a very good point um you know jobs many
jobs can go anywhere you know they don't
really have a natural-born home you know
we think that they do a lot of
politicians say that they do but they
actually don't right they can go
anywhere and not just factory jobs but
white-collar jobs knowledge jobs coding
jobs for example this is a very vaunted
category of jobs we are with there's a
lot of talk about having former factory
workers or coal miners learn coding but
that's a temporary fix at best because
the ability to code is an international
one there are people all over the world
who are fully capable of doing it it's
not necessarily an American job right so
the notion that we can keep jobs of all
sorts in the United States in the
digital age is pretty naive and you're
absolutely right that when political
candidates talk straight on this on this
point they often lose traction but I
think I traveled the United States to do
this book and in areas for example the
Rust Belt or in Kentucky in the mining
in areas of Kentucky the the residents
are actually quite aware of this you
know people are not stupid they know
what's going on
so speaking the truth on this I think is
getting to be going to be more and more
accepted because people are
understanding it so even though you know
were sometimes told for example the
marine effort right where a Chinese
manufacturer was setting up in Ohio
outside of Dayton in a former GM plant I
don't know if you were to call that once
in the recent news and in fact guess
what they're not really going to do
manufacturing there
there they pulled back dramatically on
the number of hires they're going to
make in Ohio right so this is you know a
more most recent case of this it's of
course people there now understand that
this is not something that's going to
have any durability over the long term
and I think increasingly politicians who
speak this truth will be accepted what
else in your mind counts as a temporary
solution and I guess what I'm what I'm
interested in hearing about a little bit
is universal basic income which I've
been studying for a very long time and
while I see it heavily supported by lots
of progressive economists most of them
are saying I support it as a step based
on where we are right now but it's not
really a long-term solution to the
problems that we're going to have yeah
Universal basic income is is something
that I was thrown about quite a bit
recently Silicon Valley Valley got on
board with that of course because they
in recent years have started to get to
admit that they are unemployed people
and they were concerned about that so
the whole idea of you bei and versatile
basic income was very tantalizing to
people in Silicon Valley I described it
in the book as something that should be
used as a spice now how does a main
course okay so there are examples for
example in Canada in the 1970s this
basic income was applied to a community
in Canada and it was very very helpful
okay so it was an impoverished community
or poor community and they applied it
selectively over a short term a few
years and it did lift people out of
poverty it gave them the opportunity to
become more entrepreneurial for example
in one case I interviewed some of the
people who had actually been living
there in the 1970s so for example one
guy was able to buy a truck right and
and able to be much more effective in
his agricultural efforts because he'd
had this income boost
young men were able to stay in high
school and graduate from high school
young women or young mothers were able
to stay home with their
whether infants these were all positive
things and so I believe a universal
basic income or a basic income guarantee
as it's sometimes called taking out the
word universal can be very helpful
applied selectively but of course I
don't think anyone believes it's a
long-term solution nationally it's
extremely expensive highly controversial
and it doesn't solve things over the
long term when we think about the class
impact of what's coming there are is one
point of view which says ok
technological unemployment or automation
related unemployment is going to
disproportionately affect people who are
already economically disadvantaged way
more than people who are upper middle
class and higher however a bunch of
reports that I've looked at which
estimate that anywhere between 40 and 60
percent of current jobs would be subject
to partial or full automation a lot of
those jobs are what I guess we would
call white-collar jobs or information
jobs so what is your assessment of the
truth about what the class impact will
be of this well again quite an astute
observation David in a comment um over
the I think it's not well known that
since about 2000 the demand for skill in
the United States has actually declined
okay now that's a hard thing to get your
head around because what we're told is
we need more and more education to be
competitive that more and more of us
need to graduate from college or
graduate school but in fact the demand
for skill has actually declined since
2000 it increased before that time and
therefore more more education and
specialized training was was effective
before that but since 2000 not so much
and it's because of what you're
describing the middle of less skilled
jobs have been hollowed out to a great
degree and meanwhile I spoke to oh my
god dozens of computer scientists who
told me that the kind of jobs that are
most desired to be automated or the most
skilled jobs right those are the highest
paying jobs those are the kinds of jobs
that employers would love to see
automated if they could be automated let
me give you an example there are
machines that can flip hamburgers right
now right
but fast-food outlets are not
necessarily buying those machines
because they can pay people very little
to flip hamburgers right so they don't
want to buy machines and machines are
more expensive than the people and so
why bother but if you can automate a
highly sophisticated financial advisors
job or a physicians job or a lawyer's
job the payoff is enormous so there's a
tremendous rush to see how those
particular jobs can be automated so I
think it's really naive to think that
it's only low-skilled jobs that are
becoming digitalized those were the
easiest ones to do and of course many of
them have been but the focus now is
going up the pace gal and going up the
skill scale so this is going to be kind
of a less class-based than you may think
many people are concerned about this and
are preparing for this and Millennials
and Generation Z you know people under
you know age 28 25 are finding
themselves in many cases underemployed
even though they have college degrees
they're finding that they cannot find
positions commiserate with their
education so this is something you know
we need to deal with an effective way
and something again that we have to face
rather than telling everyone they need
more and more education and more and
more skills we have to sit back and
think okay what kind of skills what kind
of education and what kind of jobs the
book is fantastic it's called the job
work and it's future and a time of
radical change it really ties together a
lot of the topics we've been talking
about on the program for a long time
we've been speaking with the books
author Ellen rupal she'll who's also a
correspondent for the Atlantic Ellen
really a pleasure speaking to you today
thank you so much Dave girl isn't it a
real pleasure the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
all right audience questions the
audience questions have been on fire
recently first question comes in via
voicemail today one of the great many
ways you can leave questions let's take
a listen to this one hey David how do
you feel about a negative income tax as
opposed to universal basic income
I think the negative income tax makes a
bit more sense because it would be a bit
more cost efficient and universal basic
income just seems a bit too far-fetched
to be honest I think that a negative
basic income tax makes a bit more sense
okay good so the question is negative
income tax versus a universal basic
income universal basic income being
where everybody just gets a certain
amount of money negative income tax
being where if you make below a certain
amount of money your income tax is
negative meaning that you end up getting
a tax refund or at least end up getting
a tax credit relative to the tax you
otherwise would have paid based on your
income so a few things number one
negative income tax requires a larger
bureaucracy to maintain because it
adjusts based on income and of course a
great question would be well if that's
the case you now are creating a hyper
incentive to reduce your adjusted gross
income on your taxes so you need more
infrastructure to sort of enforce a
negative income tax rate and the other
sort of economic factor underlying this
is that yeah it's true rich people don't
need extra money so it does make sense
generally speaking to taper off how much
money richer people get with a universal
basic income everybody just gets to
check regardless of how much you make
with a negative income tax that is
tapered off as people make more and more
and we know that the economic benefit of
giving rich people a universal basic
income is sort of minimal but again I go
back to the bureaucracy nightmare you
need way more people to sort of check
regulate and enforce a negative income
tax the basic income just says hey we
assume people are going to spend this
money and then you get money although
it's true that the richest people don't
really need that money so they'll
probably save it and it won't be
economically stimulative there's another
argument in favor of a negative income
tax which is you could more easily
implement a negative income tax by
expanding the Earned Income Tax Credit
the Earned Income Tax Credit could be
used as a sort of infrastructure to
create a negative income tax more
broadly where as a universal basic
income would be its own program but
again ubi would be way easier to manage
now in terms of the sort of political
viability I don't know one argument is
that universal basic income is going to
be a difficult political sale because it
is a new program even if it would
potentially allow the elimination of
many other programs the counter to that
is that you already have difficulty
really making the tax system any more
progressive meaning that the more you
earn the more you pay as a percentage
and a negative income tax is a hugely
progressive form of taxation and that
historically has been sort of difficult
to deal with I actually think that this
is really a difference of implementation
I think conceptually in the end the
underlying reality isn't that different
yes rich people will get less money with
a negative income tax than with ubi but
again the economic impact of those rich
people getting the basic income is nil
since they don't really need that money
and they'd probably just stick it in a
bank account so I don't actually have a
strong preference one way or the other
on this I think it's more in the details
of how its implemented do you have
strong feelings on this path that you
want to chime in on oh okay yeah I mean
it's not something that I I had to
research this I mean I was sort of aware
of both concepts and I at a general
sense of the pros and cons but for me
it's more of an implementation question
than a conceptual one the idea is let's
get people who most need some extra
money and are most likely to spend the
money in economically stimulative ways
let's figure out how to get them more
money and both programs could do it it's
a matter of how you actually put it in
place let's see let's go next to let's
go to our caller from the 605 area code
who's calling today from 6:05 all right
hi David can you hear me yeah who's this
okay this is Daniel from South Dakota
hey Daniel what's going on so I support
a living you know $15 an hour wage but
some people like inter yang has been
speaking a lot about automation recently
and so I feel that like a legitimate
concern that some people have about a
living wage is that in order to save
money companies can just automate away
their jobs and you know they'll continue
to make a profit because of that and
that's already been happening like in
fast food I've noticed with automated
kiosks and stuff so the question is is
acceleration of automation is that like
a legitimate concern at all when it
comes to a living wage if so is ubi an
effective way to counter that so listen
I mean here so the answer is yes
Automation is a concern when we think
about living wages but it's not one that
is particularly exacerbated by the
winnaman wage being $15 versus 13 and
you know a lot of people like to point
to the fast food kiosks as you talked
about
because after minimum wages were
increased in certain places you saw
fast-food locations there deploy these
kiosks those kiosks have been in
development for a very long time it
doesn't just happen overnight that the
minimum wage goes up and then all of a
sudden these kiosks show up so the truth
is that those companies have been
planning on doing that for a very long
time and so I if your argument and it
sounds like at least part of your
argument is that a $15 minimum wage is
not going to solve the problem of
technological automation I agree with
you and this is one of the big sort of
missing elements that I'm glad Andrew
yang is talking about it and many many
other elected officials are not it's
that whether the minimum wage is 13 15
or 17 number one in lots of places
that's not a living wage or it's barely
a living wage that's a real issue and
number two the issue of automation as
well as machine learning and artificial
intelligence is going to make a lot of
that minimum wage discussion not
obsolete but it's going to make it less
applicable to a lot of jobs so I'm
completely with you it's it's not being
discussed in a serious manner so would
you support having both EBI and a living
wage
yeah I've listened I'm in support of all
of those things and for people
criticize just a $15 minimum wage as
being merely a bandaid on our economic
system I agree right there there's a
bigger problem that a band-aids not
going to fix ubi of $1,000 no matter you
know I disagreed with Andrew Yang's
initial version which was the thousand
replaces other benefits I think it
should be additive but that disagreement
aside that stuff only is on the fringes
of the broader economic problems or I
guess I would call them deeper economic
problems that we have to solve alright
thank you appreciate the phone call
thank you very much great great to hear
from you let's go next to where do we
want to go next let's go next to our
caller from the four to five area code
who's calling today from four to five hi
hey Carlton now let me ask you what kind
of device are we on are we on some kind
of headset or speakerphone gotcha okay
it's it's pretty atrocious but we'll try
to deal with it what's what's your
question today here minimum wage like 13
hour but I've noticed a lot of like when
when people try to implement a $15
minimum wage deal corporations tend to
try to wiggle around in a way they don't
have to pay their employees that wage or
try to maximize profits so my question
is if we somehow implements a $15
minimum wage is this something that we
can do to kind of like make sure
inflation doesn't increase okay well
those are two separate questions so the
first question how so give me an example
of how a corporation would wiggle around
if the minimum wage is 15 an hour how do
they wiggle around that okay so a while
back one of the airports in my state
demand code says it to have a $15
minimum
seto yes so they said okay we'll give
you a 15 on minimum wage but the
downside is they cut back on employee
and put in machines the way customers
can just manually order themselves right
now that the problem with that argument
is that McDonald's was going to do that
either way and eventually anyway and
that those you know they don't within
three months of a $15 minimum wage they
don't develop and deploy those machines
in order to replace employees that's
been in the works for four years if not
a decade and that's going to happen
either way but that's where I think we
probably get to the same conclusion
which is the $15 minimum wage is a
band-aid in the same sense that a ubi of
$1,000 a month is a band-aid it doesn't
actually resolve the broader issues of
the inequality that our society creates
coming the technological unemployment
that what needs to be a different
relationship between humans and and work
so I if your argument is a $15 minimum
wage doesn't actually solve the problems
inherent to our economic system I'm
right there with you yeah what happened
what the problem is though is that
corporations they're only in it to
maximize profit yes and the only way
they'll maximize profit is they'll
increase the prices of their goods
well but you have to understand is labor
only represents a piece of the total
cost of an import of a company listen
we've addressed this before and there's
so much crazy noise on your line that
I'm gonna let you go but now we're
getting into material we've we've
already discussed before please call
back next time just on a regular phone
line and I think we'll be able to sort
of hear each other much much better the
car the car Bluetooth stuff is extremely
problematic I reserved it only for
telemarketers in my personal life
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]